[Music]
all the nice you should try on a wedding
dress you should do it lower waiting I
want to know such I went on because
you've long way you know a dress as you
are
let me pumping of the Yellen color was
good you know you won't - if he's fine
it's one dress or - what if she walked
in him in the dress what about it when
ya should have been on time so we did
one sitting here bored trying to find
something dude
the girls are me a child waiting dressed
because I had a man in the dress since I
started losing weight but I'm kind of
apprehensive doing were supposed to be
years for a law and not me okay miss
Sara key yes absolutely I want to try to
get my mom in one of these oh okay I
didn't realize she was bride she's mine
but he's lost a lot of wedding I mean so
so better than now and well sure look
what she saw it that's why I'll take you
nowhere
well ah no no come on while I do it
it's do it no just a wang friend
literally you're not getting married
what's out of this Wow well I'm saying
finish to us on Twitter
trust me you can well go let's marijuana
wear some help push your hair okay calm
so we just gotta be quick about this I
mean I'm not getting married anytime
soon but I'm kind of curious time I look
in the wedding dress Oh y'all ready yeah
we've been ready come on now time or
wait 9 you oh my god here we think um
y'all difference
your mama was bull I mean she did go
from a size 22 to a 12 with his damn
good burn
Wow right on a little hourglass design
you look like a movie star I may not
want to be getting married but damn I
look mighty hot in a wedding dress
I'll check facts let me know if you need
me okay just looks like a movie star
oh my god I'm jumping she can't exercise
let's land off your being Hodel and your
thoughts on that waitress fine pop some
pictures Leslie I'm sure she is
[Music]